Hello, everyone.
Welcome to
my lecture, the
spinal cord.
In this hour, we are
going to describe
the physical
geometry of the
spinal cord, especially
the different
gray and white
matter divisions,
including nuclei and lung
tracts, as well
as spinal reflex.
The goal is you
should be able to
identify different
levels of the spinal cord
based on the
neurological deficits.
Be sure to look at the
detailed objectives
in the CPG as well as
scholar Rx bricks. I
have mapped this
lecture concepts
into the complex
blueprint. You can
see here the complex
blueprint has
dimensions and
clinical presentations.
So both clinical
presentation
four and five has a very
relevant spinal
cord information.
We also mapped it to
USMLE blueprint and
you can see here
with the nervous
system and special
senses there are normal
process as well as
abnormal processes.
So these are highly
relevant to the spinal
cord so highlight the
importance of this.
The initial 10 ish
slides are all review
so I'm going to go
through them really
quickly so as you can
see the spinal cord
is located inside the
vertebra and there
are three layers of
meninges with the
cushion of cerebral
spinal fluid there are
31 pairs of spinal
nerves but only 30
vertebra so there
is a C8 the cervical
eight spinal nerve
actually exiting in
between the cervical
and thoracic vertebra.
There are two
enlargements, one
cervical, one lumbar
sacral ***********.
And these enlargements
are correlating
with the upper
body or arms and
lower body or the
legs innervation.
And the spinal cord
end early. They
don't reach all the
spinal vertebrae. They
actually ended by
the lumbar two spinal
vertebra the very
end of the spinal
cord right here is
called conus medullaris
and you have this
big bundles of
spinal nerve forming
like a horse tail
and the latin name of
the horse tail quad
equina is given to
describe this structure
and then you also have
this fiber-like, very
hard fiber-like
structure called film
terminali. It's
extending from the column
medullarius all the way
down to connect with the
vertebra. This is
formed from pure matter
to anchor the spinal
cord and stabilize it.
And this kind of
brings us to ask the
question, how do we sample
the CSF? What is the
optimal location that
we can insert our
needle to extract the
cerebrospinal fluid?
As you can imagine,
we wanted to reach
into the large area
that has the lumbar
cistern, that has a
lot of CSF, but without
the major spinal cord
tissue themselves,
right? So because
the spinal cord ended
at the lumbar 2 level,
that's why when we
try to sample, we
can insert our needle
in between either 3
or 4 or in between
lumbar 4 and 5 vertebra
to extract the CSF.
Similarly, we could
do the intrathecal
injections to deliver
drugs or epidural
injections reach
the same area of the
spinal vertebra so
with the meninges of
the spinal cord as
you can compare with a
cranial meninges we
have several different
special features
so with the dura
matter the spinal cord
has only one layer
instead of two layers
for the cranium.
And for the peer
matter, there's also
a special feature
called denticulate
pigment. So it's this
type of structure.
These are coming
from the peer matter
that's forming to
attach with the dura
matter to stabilize
the spinal cord.
and here are the major
differences between
the cranial
meninges and spinal
meninges you can fill
in the blank yourself
but main ones are
the dura mater has
single layered in
the spinal cord and
there is a real space
at epidural space in
between the dura
and the vertebrae
periosteum. And we
also have the special
denticulate ligament
at the spinal cord.
In terms of the bony
structure, the spinal
cord actually is
very well protected
inside the spinal
vertebra. So the dorsal
aspect is a spinous
process, and then
the ventral aspect
is a vertebral body.
Now let's look at
the cross-section of
the spinal cord. As
you can see here,
the spinal cord is
relatively small.
Alongside the axis
of the spinal cord,
there is gray matter,
and you can see
here that's where
the cell body is
located. And then
you have white matter
surrounding the gray
matter. Those are
the axons or the
lung tracts located.
And the gray matter
always have this
butterfly shape and you
can divide that into
the dorsal horn which
is on the dorsal
side and also ventral
horn that's on the
ventral side and
you would have this
coming into the
dorsal horn that's the
dorsal root and then
coming out of the
ventral horn would be
the ventral root what
happens if there is
a disc herniation we
always heard about
patients have the disc
carnation, right?
And this is a disc.
We can look at
it, a detailed
structure in
the next slide.
So the disc, you
know, the name of it,
you can imagine
it's like a ring
structure. So basically
you have this ring.
The outside is an
annulus. It's a hard ring
structure and the inside
is nucleus. That's
a soft tissue, almost
like the spinal cord
itself. So you can see
this ring type structure
located in between
the two vertebrae. And
when there is any
lesion to this ring
structure, you can see
the bulging out of this
nucleus materials that
can press on either
the spinal root or press
on the ventral horn
of the spinal cord. And
that will cause either
the sensory deficits
like, you know, strong
pain and numbness,
or you can experience
weakness because the
ventral horn is controlling
the motor function
of the spinal cord.
Showing here in more
details the cross
section of the spinal
cord this is one spinal
segment as you can see
you have the dorsal
horn connect with
the dorsal rootlets a
bunch of small rootlets
forming the dorsal
root and then you have
the dorsal ventral
rootlets coming out
of the ventral horn
forming the ventral
root and the dorsal root
and ventral root
merge into a spinal
nerve and there is a
famous structure called
dorsal root ganglion.
This is where the
cell bodies of the
primary neurons located.
And this dorsal root
ganglion innervating,
you know, sending the
axons to the dorsal
horn of the spinal
cord that's sending the
sensory information
in into the segment.
Each segment
innervates a dermatome.
So this segment will
have the innervation
of a specific
area of the skin.
As you can see here,
this is a mat for which
nerve innervating
which territory on the
skin. As you can see,
they're all color-coded
from the cervical all
the way to the sacral
and coccygeal segment
of the spinal nerves.
So for the cervical,
I don't know if you
notice that it's
actually starting from
number two to eight
what happened to c1
so turns out that c1
spinal nerve does not
have the skin
representation it actually
innervates the dura
the cerebral meninges
and there's also the
v1 to v3 so as you can
imagine this is the
trigeminal nerve, the
three branches for
the trigeminal nerve.
You do need to remember
the general locations
of these different
segments innervation.
The dermatome
territory is shown very
distinctively in this
disease called shingles. So
you can see here the
characteristic type of
zoster that's resulted
from ****** virus
infection so this is the
one dermatome usually
caused by childhood
infection and then it
becomes dormant and and
the virus is hidden in
the dorsal ganglion
DRG and usually in the
adulthood when there's
an immune system you
know decreased function
like some kind of
compromise due to stress
or aging, these viruses
can be reactivated
and produce these very
characteristic rash
within the same dermatome.
So this is one DRG
related dermatome, and
it's usually on one
side of the body. It
doesn't cross midline
to go to the other side.
Okay, so we
talked about the
dorsal horn or
posterior horn,
anterior horn or ventral
horn. There's also
a lateral horn called
intermediate gray.
So the lateral horn is
hosting the autonomic
neurons, which we're
going to cover later.
And this is the gray
matter division.
For the white matter,
we also have, you
know, the gray matter
dividing the white matter
into three segments.
So there is posterior
segment, which is
this area, and then
you have the lateral
funiculus, which is
this large area, and
then you also anterior
funiculus. So these
three areas are
hosting different
long tracks that
are important
for the function.
As you can see here
on the left side,
we're showing the
large myelinated fibers
coming into the dorsal
horn deeper lamina
and synapse with
the forming some
reflexes. It also goes
ipsilateral to the
upper level to the
medulla. And then we also
have small thin
fibers that come in to
carry the pain and
temperature information
and synapse directly
at the spinal
cord dorsal horn, the
superficial layer.
And we also have
this large myelinated
motor neurons
that's called
lower motor neurons
that are sending
the axons to
innervate the muscles.
At the intermediate
grade, the lateral
horn, you have the
autonomic neurons
sending out the
fibers, usually
are small and non
-myelinated. Another
way of separating
the different layers
of the gray matter
is called laminae of
rex. So the gray
matter can be divided
into 10 different
lamina. And you can
see here the
superficial dorsal horn,
those two laminas,
one and two, is
more for the pain
and temperature
information called
substantia gelatinosa.
And then there's a
nucleus proprius.
That's more for the
center order neurons
for the pain and
temperature sensation.
And for the column
of Clark's, this
is more for the
signals, the
proprioception
signals going to the
cerebellum for the
motor coordination.
And the lateral horn
we talked about is
autonomic nervous
system, the preganglionic
neurons located. And
then for the ventral
horn, there is a small
map that's showing
the top or bottom half
of the ventral horn
is innervating either
flexors or extensors.
Or if we divided the
ventral horn from the
medial versus the
lateral portion, then the
medial portion is for
the proximal part of
the limb and lower body.
Or the lateral segment
is for the distal
part of the limb. The
neurotransmitters
secreted in
the spinal cord
is similar to
the brain,
relatively simple,
with excitatory
neurotransmitters
and inhibitory
neurotransmitters.
The major excitatory
neurotransmitters
are glutamate and
acetylcholine.
And glutamate is
mainly for the primary
afferent as well as
descending projection neurons,
while acetylcholine
is for the autonomic
preganglionic neurons.
and also lower motor
neurons using for
innervating the muscles.
Inhibitory
neurotransmitters, there is a
special type called
glycine. So the glycine
inhibitory neurotransmitters
is specifically
located in the
renshaw cells, the
interneurons. And those
transmitters are uniquely
located in the spinal
cord and brainstem.
GABA is also widely
distributed in
the spinal cord,
as well as in the
brain. There are
also a bunch of
neuropeptide producing
neuromodulatory
effect. Those are
usually related with
pain, such as Sutton's
P, enkeletons, and
CGRP, calcitonin
gene-related peptide.
The importance
of interneurons
can be shown clearly
by this disease
called tetanus.
So tetanus is
caused by the
infection of these gram
-positive bacteria
called Clostridia
tetanine through
the open wounds.
And those bacteria
release tetanospasmin,
which is a proteinase
that can cleave the
snare protein to
block neurotransmitter
release from the
inhibitor interneurons,
like blocking the GABA
and glycine release.
so the result is uh you
know the muscle cannot
relax and it's
maintained in the *******
state and so for uh
so if this happens the
infection happens in
the brain stem then
you would see the
uh recess sardonicus
which means the sardonic
smile so basically
you can see the facial
muscles are uh you
know in the contracted
state and you have
this a permanent grin
and raised eyebrows
and also it can be
uh you know shown as
a locked draw the
trismus if it happens
in the spinal cord
blocks the ring shell
cells of the glycine
release then you would
have this very
characteristic body gesture
um like uh you know
the extensor muscles
are contracted and it's
called opistotonous.
Basically, it's
the opposite tone.
So kind of you see all
the muscle contraction
in the limbs and
the back as well. So
very painful form. The
treatment is usually
preventative. We do
every 10 years, we do
boosters of the vaccine
and then you can
use diazepam to relax
the muscles and use
antibiotics to treat
the infection itself
okay let's look
at some of the
spinal reflexes
it's a basic
pattern of motor
coordination
the most famous one
probably we know here
you know it's a knee
**** reflex right
the doctor using
a little hammer to
knock underneath a
patient's knees. It's
heavily modified by
the descending input.
The simplest reflex is
called stretch reflex.
So the stretch reflex
is only involving
two neurons. So one
sensory neuron that's
sending the information
into the spinal
cord, synapse with the
one motor neuron that
sent the innervation
to the same muscle.
So you can see
here the doctor
using a little
hammer tapping
to induce a
patellar reflex.
So this is a
monosynaptic reflex
that involves
only one synapse,
monosynaptic. And
it's also called deep
tendon reflex. These
deep tendon reflex
have a specific use
by the neurologist.
Now, the question is what
neurotransmitters
are released in this
monosynaptic
stretch reflex?
The answer is glutamate
and acetylcholine.
So glutamate is
released by the
primary neuron,
sensory neurons, and
acetylcholine is
released by this
motor neuron to
innervate the muscle.
These are the important
spinal reflex that's
being tested a lot
by the neurologist.
So you do need to
remember what are the
correlating spinal cord
segments related with
these reflexes. In
the first aid, there
is a mnemonics to help
you remember these.
So, one, two,
buckle my shoe,
Achilles reflex.
And then three, four,
kick the door with
your patellar reflex.
Five, six, pick up
sticks, use your
hand. And then
seven, eight, laid
out straight,
that would be your
triceps reflex.
So remember those.
the second reflex i'd
like to introduce is
called withdrawal
reflex a classic example
for withdrawal reflex
is when we touch
the hot stove you know
we immediately withdraw
our hand and then
before we even know
it right so this response
is a quick response
from the spinal
reflex and this reflex
obviously is more
complex than the simplest
deep tendon reflex.
As you can see,
interneurons are involved
with this process.
And so it involves
multiple muscle as well.
Some are activated and
others are inhibited.
And during this process,
the neurotransmitters
involved will
include not only the
glutamate and
acetylcholine, but also
glycine. So as we
mentioned previously,
the glycine is in
the interneurons, the
major inhibitor
neurotransmitters there.
This is an even
more complex reflex
called cross
extensor reflex.
The example is that
if we step on a sharp
object with one foot
then immediately you
withdraw one foot you
know you lift up this
one foot but then you
have to put the weight
and shift your balance
to the other side the
other foot and so this
process involves a
lot of interneurons
and multiple muscles
within both limbs you
can imagine all these
neurotransmitters would
be involved as well
Okay,
so we've talked about the
spinal cord gray matter.
Now we're going to
move on to the spinal
white matter. Before we
do that, make sure you
take a deep breath,
take a coffee break,
or take a short walk.
Whatever can make you
relax and then come
back with a fresh mind.
Drawing here,
you see the blue
color-coded
sensory tracks and
red color-coded
motor tracks.
Note that these tracks
are bilateral, so
they're symmetrical,
not only on one side.
Don't panic when you
see so many tracks
here. We're only
going to focus on
three major long
tracks in this lecture.
We have two ascending
or sensory tracks that
collecting the
information from
the peripheral
and then send
information into
the spinal cord.
Specifically, cunid
fasciculus and gracile
fasciculus are
forming the dorsal
column. This is a
DCML pathway to carry
the touch and
properception information.
And then we also
have spinothalamic
tract. The spinosalamic
tract is carrying
the pain and
temperature information
from the peripheral
to the brain.
And then we also
have a major motor
tract called the
lateral corticospinal
tract. This is
coming from the
motor cortex to
innervate the muscles.
Let's talk about the
ascending pathways first.
So for ascending
pathways means the
information comes
from the peripheral
and being sent up
to the cerebral
cortex to have the
sensation of a different
aspect of the
sensory function.
And the first one
is called the DCML
pathway. So all
of these ascending
pathways has three
neuron relays. They
have the first primary
A-frame neurons.
We also call it
first order neurons.
These neurons for the
touch and proprioception
is located at the
dorsal root ganglion
with the cell body.
And then the fibers
are sending inside
the spinal cord via
the fasciculus cuneatus
and uh fasciculus
gracilis so those
two are in charge of
the lower limb and
upper limbs so the
fasciculus gracilis
is located more medial
to the dorsal column
and then the fasciculus
cuneatus is located
more lateral so
how to remember this
uh if you remember a
person you know this
is a person's body.
And then you can
imagine the legs are
more in the middle
and the arms are
more sticking out.
So the medial part
is the fasciculus
gracilis and the
lateral part is
fasciculus cuneatus that
carrying the upper
limb information.
So that's a
primary afferent or
first order neurons
so located inside
the dorsal column
and we can see
the secondary
order neurons here
at the medulla level
so from the spinal cord
you would have this
information being sent
up and then synapse at
this medulla secondary
order neurons right
here at nucleus gracilis
or nucleus cuneatus.
So these secondary
order neurons will send
the axons and cross
the midline to form
medial lemniscus. So the
first part is a dorsal
column, DC, and the
second order neurons
send axons to form ML,
so medial lemniscus.
And so that's why this
pathway is called DC
-ML pathway. way. And so
second order neurons
send the axons out to
the contralateral side
and then reach the
third order neurons
that are located at the
thalamus. And then from
here, it will go up to
the somatosensical cortex
with the perception
of the pain of the
touch and properception
sensation. so the
decussion point is at
medulla this is very
important for judging what
happens with the lesions
at each level now
what happens if there
is some lesion to
these long tracts so
please pay attention
here this is very
difficult material so for
example if i have a
lesion to the fasciculus
gracilis at the
lumbar spinal cord,
a lesion on the
left side, for
example, what
kind of deficit
would the patient
experience?
Think about it. So
the information now is
carried from the left
side of the lower limb,
right, the legs or
the lower body. This
information will be
cut so it's not able to
pass through to be
transmitted to the brain
right so that's why
you have this deficit
from the same side or
the left side of the
of the body the left
lower limb if you have
a lesion here at the
cervical cord dorsal
column now the information
is not only carried
from the leg, but
also carried from the
arms, right? From the
left arm is coming
into the spinal cord at
this level. So if you
have a lesion here,
then you would have
the deficit from both
the arm and the leg of
the same side, you
know, of the left side.
So you're what we call
the ipsilateral deficit.
So ipsilateral means the
same side of the lesion,
you know, which is
the star here, and
the deficit, you
know, and the lack of
sensation. They're
on the same side.
So now this is happening
in the spinal cord level.
What happens when it's
above the decosition?
So remember, we
talked about this
fiber, You know, once
they reach the medulla,
they're actually
changed to the second
order neurons that
send the axons to the
contralateral side
and then ascending.
Right. So when
lesions happens on the
let's say on the right
hand side, either
at the palms,
midbrain or thalamus,
if you have a lesion
on the right side.
that above the
decosition or after the
decosition, what side
of the body is going to
not experience the
touch and perception?
So the answer is the
contralateral side.
What do I mean
by contralateral
side? So right
now, the lesion
is on the right
side, right?
On information being
passed along by this
part of the medial
amniscus actually comes
from the left side of
the body, right? So
the information comes
in from here to the
spinal cord and then
cross to the other side,
contralateral side,
and all the way up
to the brain. So this
is when you have any
lesions above this
decussition or after this
decussition, you're
going to see lack of
touch and proprioception
information being
transmitted from the
left side of the body.
That means after the
decussition, you're
going to have
contralateral deficit, but
before the decussition
at the spinal level,
you're going to see
ipsilateral deficit.
Okay, after you
understand the DCML
pathway, the
spinothalamic tract
would be much easier
to appreciate.
So the major
difference is that
the spinothalamic
tract is carrying
pain and temperature
sensation.
It also has three neuron
relays. The primary
afferent neurons, or
first-order neurons,
are collecting the
information from the
peripheral send the
information to the dorsal horn
of the spinal cord
and then synapse right
here to the secondary
order neurons at the
dorsal horn of the
spinal cord previously we
mentioned the substantial
latinosa and nucleus
proprius at the
superficial layer of the
spinal cord dorsal horn
the cell body located
there they send the
axons out and then these
axons are crossing
the midline at the
anterior white commissure
and alongside the
spinosalamic tract STT
and then goes all the way
up to the thalamus to
see that's at the third
order neurons here.
So the third order
neurons send out the
axons all the way to the
somatosensory cortex.
That's where we have
the pain sensation. So
this pathway is a little
more straightforward
since it doesn't have
the differentiation
between the lower limb
and the upper limb.
So all of these are
corresponding with the
specific spinal segment.
So when the lesions
happen to this pathway
anywhere along the
spinal cord or in the
brain most majority
of the time the lesion
you know on let's
say on the right side
you would experience
the pain and temperature
deficit on the left
side of the body
because of this
decomposition happens
right here at the
spinal cord level
so when you have
any lesion of the
spinophilamic tract,
almost always you
would have the
contralateral deficit.
So that means the
body is on the
one side and the
lesion is on the
other side. So
contralateral deficit.
I like to mention
here, this is a
small diagram, but
it's also important
in terms of the,
you know, which side
is the leg, which
side is the arm
information. So for
the DCML pathway,
you remember that the
fasciculus gracilis
carrying the leg
information is more medial
at the spinal cord,
right? And for the
spinosalamic tract, it's
the opposite. So the
leg information is
carried more lateral
compared to the arm
information. So you just
need to remember one,
and then the other
one is the opposite.
That would be enough.
Okay, let's summarize
what we have
talked about for the
ascending pathways.
For the ascending
sensory pathways, we
talked about lesions
before the decusition
is causing
ipsilateral deficits.
So before decusition
for the DCML
pathway is uh you
know in the spinal
cord right because
the decomposition
happens at the
medulla level
and then for uh after
the decomposition then
you would see the
contralateral deficit
which means the deficit
and the lesion side
are uh on the contrary
are on the opposite
side similarly for the
pain and temperature
pathway because of the
decomposition happens
right at the spinal
cord level. That's why
lesion of the spinothalamic
tract would almost
always cause the
contralateral deficit.
So that's the
summarized statement.
Okay, now let's look
at the descending
pathways controlling
the motor
activity. The
major one is called
corticospinal tract.
That's one of the most
important voluntary
movement tract.
If you want to
carry a coffee, you
know, want to drink
coffee, you need
to reach out to
the coffee cup. And
those muscle
coordinations are all
coming from the
corcospinal tract.
So this tract,
just from the name,
you can imagine
that it starts from
the cortex, from
the motor cortex.
If you remember the
anatomy lab, this is
precentral gyrus,
right? and then the cell
body is located in
that precentral gyrus
and the axons comes
all the way down to
the spinal cord and
you know over here when
passing the pyramid
there is a decosition
that it goes to the
contralateral side
and then going down
the spinal cord then
comes into the ventral
horn of the spinal
cord and the synapse at
the lower motor neuron
here at the ventral
horn to innervate
the muscle. So this
is a very long tract.
And that's why, you
know, when we have
this two neuron relay,
this top one from
the cortex all the
way to the spinal cord
is called upper motor
neuron. And then
the cell bodies located
in the ventral horn,
those are called
lower motor neurons.
So this is a major
corticospinal tract.
Remember the decosition
is at the pyramid.
So pyramid is right
at the junction
between medulla and
a spinal cord. Now
what happens with the
lesion for the descending
tract? So remember
the descending tract,
the direction is this
way. So we have the
decosition at the
pyramid. And then so this
part you know from
the cortex all the way
to the pyramid this is
before the decosition
and then all
the spinal cord
because now you
pass the decosition
this is after
the decosition
so if we have a lesion
at the spinal cord
you can imagine that if
we have a lesion here
then this corticospinal
tract would
not be able to
control the neurons
that are innervating
the muscles at
the ipsilateral
side. So therefore,
if any lesions at the
spinal level, you
would experience the
ipsilateral deficit
of the motor control.
And on the contrary,
if you have any lesion
at the upper level
above the pyramid, then
you can see that this
track will not be
able to come down to
innervate the opposite
side of the muscle.
That's why you're
going to have the
contralateral deficit.
So contralateral
deficit here.
So in summary, for
the descending tracks,
lesions before the
decosition cause
contralateral deficit
right this is before
and the lesions after
the decomposition
will cause the ipsilateral
deficit therefore
at the spinal
level it's always
ipsilateral deficit
ipsilateral paralysis
below the level of
lesions now let's look
at the general rules
of lateralization
as we just talked,
for the descending
tracts, the
lesions before the
decosition causing
the contralateral
deficit, and the
lesions after the
decosition cause
ipsilateral deficit.
On the contrary, for
the ascending tracts,
we were talking about
that lesions before
the decosition will cause
ipsilateral deficit,
and lesions after
the decosition will
cause the contralateral
deficits. So these are
completely opposite,
right? You see that.
So in order to simplify
this complex rule,
I actually noticed
that for both ascending
and descending tracks,
we actually have
a consistent conclusion
if we use below the
decaxation and above
the decaxation. So
below decaxation means
along the neurexis.
So spinal cord would
be below the brainstem
medulla and the
brainstem medulla would
be lower than the
cortex. So this is like
this is like above so
this is like below.
That's the neurexis
along the neurexis.
So for both ascending
and descending
tracks, they could
become consistent
if we use this below
and above decosition
rule. Because for
ascending tracks,
before decosition is
actually below the
decosition, but for
descending track, the before
decosition is actually
above decosition.
So let me illustrate
a little bit more.
in the here again we
have our ascending
tracks and descending
lung tracks so the
ascending we have the
dcml and the spinothalamic
tract that are going
up and then for
the descending we
have the corticospinal
tract that coming
down with the signals
And as you can see
here, the decomposition
for DCML is at the
medulla level. And
when we have before
the decomposition,
then we'll see the
ipsilateral deficit.
When we have after the
decomposition, we'll
see the contralateral
deficit. This is
because the signal is
carried by the same
side of the of the tract
or the contralateral
side of the tract
so similarly for
the ascending tract
of spinosalamic tract
the decision is right
at the spinal cord
level and then you
have a very short small
before decomposition
circuitry which is
the primary sensory
neurons as well as
the dorsal horn before
the synapse, right?
But most
majority, once it
forms a
spinosalamic tract,
it would always be
on the contralateral
side. So you have
a large proportion
of after the
decosition and a very
small proportion of
before decosition.
For the descending
tract, the corticospinal
tract, we have the
decosition at the
pyramid level. And so
you have also a pretty
long before decosition
and after decosition
at the spinal cord
levels. Anything above
the spinal would be
before the decosition.
And we explained
previously that for
the before decosition,
you would have
contralateral
deficit. For after
decosition, you have
lipidolateral deficit.
So if we combine these,
you know, unify these
together by drawing
a line about where
the decomposition
is, you can see
that above the
decomposition, you would
see the contralateral
deficit, regardless
whether it's
ascending or descending
track. Versus when
it's below the
decomposition, you would
always have the
ipsilateral deficit.
Ipsilateral means
the lesion and the
deficits are on the
same side of the body.
That was a hard segment
of this lecture.
So make sure you
look at those
slides and then
think about
the side
lateralization again.
And, you know, this
is the hardest part
for the neuroblock
is, you know, be able
to deduct which side
of the lesion and
which level of the
lesion would cause a
specific deficit and
vice versa. So if
you see some kind
of a presentation of
the problems the
patient is experiencing,
then you would be
able to identify
which side the
lesion possibly
would be and
at which level.
So that's the very
important skill to have.
Okay, let's look
at the blood
supply for the
spinal cord.
For the blood
supply, there are two
arteries. One is
the posterior spinal
artery, which is at
the dorsal surface.
There are actually
two posterior spinal
arteries, you know,
one on each side. But
there's only one
anterior spinal artery
that's coming off of
the vertebral artery. So
one anterior spinal
artery at the ventral
or anterior surface
of the spinal cord.
So the territory looks
just like that. so
the anterior spinal
artery innervating the
ventral horn and part
of the most majority
part of the lateral
the ciculus and then
for the posterior artery
you have the location
at the dorsal horn
as well as the dorsal
column so that's a
territory now the
question is what
deficits would you expect
with anterior spinal
artery ******? And what
about the posterior
spinal artery ******?
Now let's look at
the exact deficit we
should be expecting
when there is anterior
or posterior spinal
artery strokes.
So knowing their
territory, we can
relatively easily
deduct what type of a
deficit we would
be seeing. So first
structure is at
the ventral horn
neurons. So these
alpha motor neurons are
innervating specific
muscles, right?
So these muscle fibers
are innervated by
these large neurons
sending out the axons. So
when there's a lesion
of the ventral horn
you would expect the
same level of the
lesion would experience
the same level of deficit
so the muscles
innervated directly by
these neurons would
not be able to contract
so it's going to be on
the same side and you
know the it's going
to impact only the
myotome innervated by
these specific neurons.
For a large tract like
white matter tract,
the upper motor neuron
within the corticospinal
tract here, it
would be a different
story because these
fiber bundles are fed
by the fibers coming
through from above
this level all the
way down to below this
level, right? So for
example, if this is
our cervical level,
that if you cut the
fibers here at the
cervical, let's say C3,
then you would have
problem contracting
the muscles from
the upper limb as
well as from the
lower limb because
all of these fibers
would be severed.
So everything
down below would
not receive the
innervation.
So you have that
below level of lesion
and, you know, it's
a lateral deficit.
For the third one
right here, so
this is our
spinothalamic tract.
Same thing, the lung
fibers, you know,
these bundle of
fibers are fed in
from all the fibers
below this, you
know, cervical C3
level, for example.
So then you would
see the pain and
temperature deficit
for the C3 and
below. So you would
have upper and lower
limb pain and
temperature deficit.
Now are you able to
deduct what kind of
deficit you would
experience with
posterior spinal artery
strokes so we know
the posterior artery
****** the territory
is on the you know
the dorsal end of
the spinal cord so
that's kind of the
boundary for posterior
spinal arteries
and then number
four is our
dorsal column so
the dorsal column
Like, again, it's a
white matter, large
bundle of fibers
that's being fed in by
all the fibers below
this C3 level. So
you're going to see the
below level deficits
with fine touch
and proprioception.
And then these are
on the ipsilateral
side because they're
still below the
level of decomposition,
right? The
decomposition happens
in the medulla.
and here for the gray
matter you know the
dorsal horn this is
the same thing as our
ventral horn you know
with the gray matter
lesion you would see
only the same level
of the lesion you can
you're going to see
the deficit so it's at
the level of dermatome
only because these
dorsal horn neurons
are receiving information
from this specific
patch of skin, specific
sensory neurons
that coming in to
synapse at this dorsal
horn and then goes through
this secondary order
neurons to cross the
midline and then feed
into the other side
spinothalamic tract.
so it's only receiving
the information from
this dermatome from
these primary sensory
neurons so the deficit
would be on the
same side because
this is before our
decomposition right and
with this dermatome only
right that's all
the long tracks
that we covered
for this section.
As you can see here,
this is summary
slide. Let's go
over these again.
So with the red line,
this is, you know, the
sensory information
comes in to the dorsal
horn of the spinal
cord. This is related to
the pain and temperature
information because
you can see it's a
thin, unmyelinated or
thinly myelinated or
unmyelinated axons coming
into the spinal cord
synapse as a second
-order neurons at the
substantia gelatinosa or
nucleus proprius and
the second order neurons
send the axons over
to the other side
cross anterior white
commissure to reach
spinothalamic tract so
the spinothalamic tract is
on the opposite side
of where the sensory
information coming in so
the decaxation happens
right here at anterior
white commissure.
Now the second
ascending pathway is
for the touch and
proprioception.
So this is the very
thick myelinated
axons coming into
the spinal cord. It
can synapse at the
deeper level of the
dorsal horn or just
go ipsilaterally
up to reach medulla
where they have the
decomposition at
the medulla level.
For the DCML dorsal
column medial
amniscus pathway, we
have two segments.
One segment is
fasciculus gracilis. The
second one is fasciculus
cuneatus. And the
fasciculus gracilis is
innervating the lower
limbs or the lower
body. So that's in the
medial side of the
dorsal column. On the
latter side of the
dorsal column, the
fasciculus cuneatus appears
only in the cervical
spinal cord, and
that's for the upper
body and upper limb,
like arms and hands. So
those two parts
forming the posterior
column or dorsal column.
And then this dorsal
column synapses at
medulla, at brainstem,
and then becomes, you
know, decacit, and
then goes to the
other side, become
medial amniscus. So
that's the DCML pathway.
And for the major
descending pathway,
we have the lateral
corticospinal tract.
This one, the
cortical cell body is
coming from the
contralateral side of the
motor cortex at the
precentral gyrus,
and then decasite at
the pyramid level,
and comes down to
the spinal cord,
and then eventually
synapse with the
lower motor neurons
at the ventral horn.
So that's the
three major tracks.
Now, test yourself.
See what happens
with these lesions,
you know, the lesions
at these areas that
are marked with
the lines. And think
about what kind of
deficit you should
be looking at. And
here's the answer.
You can compare
your notes with the
conclusion here.
And
that's all for
this lecture if you
have any questions
feel free to email
me and if you
have any feedbacks
please use this link
to send me some of
the suggestions
thank you very much